there are hundreds of scripted
television series and with cable
channels streaming services and even
tech companies like Facebook and Apple
creating their own original programming
the list of TV options is only getting
more crowded network TV might not be the
trendiest destination these days but
after all these decades they still know
what they're doing in fact the network
still produce consistently impressive
content even if much of it seems to get
lost in the shuffle here are some of the
best Network TV shows that nobody's
talking about agents of shield if you
stopped watching ABC's agents of shield
after its first season it's high time to
get back on board the Marvel series
resurrects the character Phil Coulson to
lead a team of shield agents who have to
deal with an array of small screen
villains the show has been able to pick
up some of the weirder and the more
obscure corners of Marvel Comics that
are passed over in the films making it a
great series for fans of the comics and
it's fun plotting and likeable
characters make it worth a watch even
for people who want comic book readers
did you just give me a compliment the
show's sixth season is set to return in
the summer of 2019 after the release of
Avengers 4 giving viewers who haven't
seen the series plenty of time to catch
up on this hidden gem fresh off the boat
ABC has some major hits in their family
comedy block in addition to the highly
acclaimed sitcoms Modern Family &
blackish the network's best household
may be in a delightful 1990s set sitcom
fresh off the boat the show stars always
brilliant Constance Wu as an uptight
Taiwanese immigrant raising three boys
in Orlando Florida recent seasons are
flown largely under the radar but with
one of the best casting comedy
television fresh off the boat remains
must-see TV good girls men have gotten
their fair share of TV anti-heroes but
women finally get theirs and NBC's good
girls
robbery the crime drama series centers
around three mom to get in over their
heads after robbing a local grocery
store the cast has brilliant and a many
plot twists keep the show moving at a
swift pace your girls was met with
moderate reviews from critics at the
start but continued to improve
throughout its run eventually earning an
A rating from Entertainment Weekly for
its season one finale it's hard to
predict where the show will go next
which makes it exactly the kind of fun
soapy rive you want to get on speechless
it's not easy to successfully combine
heart and humor but that's precisely
what the ABC sitcom speechless has done
the series follows a family whose oldest
son has cerebral palsy leaving him as a
show's title suggests speechless
critics have noted that the show's
handling of the characters disability is
impressive with an indie wire review
saying the show is actively anti
tokenism and exemplifies simple human
decency without emphasizing it with a
talented cast led by Minnie Driver as a
family's matriarch speech this as a
comedy gem you don't want to miss
superstore there are a lot of workplace
comedies so it's easy for some to get
lost in the shuffle but NBC's superstore
definitely deserves a closer look the
show stars Golden Globe winner America
Ferrera as an employee at the fictional
superstore cloud9
despite the familiarity of its premise
superstore has been consistently funny
throughout its run and boasts a diverse
hilarious cast the series might not have
the biggest star power but it's one of
the most reliable comedies on TV when
you really need a laugh yeah I'm
generally a cynic but this
Wow trial and error the courtroom is
always ripe for drama but hasn't
inspired many modern comedy series MBC
filled that hole with their legal
anthology mockumentary trial-and-error
which features a young lawyer and an
assistant district attorney who tried
New York's toughest cases aside from the
show's ability to recruit big stars it's
also earned positive reviews from
critics
is this something people have been
talking about with a wacky sense of
humor trial and error often gets much
more bizarre than its premise would
suggest making each episode a hilarious
comedic surprise izombie comic-book
properties may be all the rage but most
viewers are sleeping on one of the best
comic book adaptations on TV The CW's
iZombie is a smart funny and
quick-witted adaptation of the vertigo
series of the same name in the iZombie
universe eating someone's brains gives
you a hint about how they passed away
and Medical Examiner live who happens to
be a zombie uses her skill to assist the
Seattle Police Department in solving
their most difficult cases by zombies
procedural elements are consistent
delights of what has made the series
truly great as the expansion of its
world balancing week-to-week storylines
with season-long storylines the show
posed compelling characters and fun
romance thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're loved today
[Music]